okay what's up guys Lord slavin here for
the iron Lord
podcast.net back again to pack since
and I'm here with Celia Schilling he
director of marketing Yacht Club games
oh and I'm very excited because we are
looking at Nina the hollow yeah sorry
about that
too
a game that has been done
oh God
tell us about me oh yeah
yeah okay so we announced Mira on
recipes a little bit over a year ago we
decided to go back to our route so we
actually launched the kickstarter on it
within eight hours we were over funded
throughout the throughout the whole
campaign
all of our backers we're working very
hard on this project so I'm so excited
to get into your hands but about the
gate
um Samina is a love letter to the Game
Boy Color I'm a huge Gameboy Kid myself
so um ah I love it uh it is a top-down
action adventure game
um we lean really into the spooky
but gameplay-wise I would compare it
similar way too I'm I'm like a
Castlevania mixed in with a link to
listening mixed with a little bit of a
bloodborne so there's a lot of
challenges yeah
I would definitely like our it's so
funny that like our company like a lot
of the things we make are retro rooted
but like we've been in love with video
games since we saw our first pick call
and so it only makes sense to express
that love in creating games that are uh
familiar with you absolutely as an old
man
oh yeah
okay
so for this on this demo you can choose
which item that you want to use
R which is like for cool with you can
choose the hammer uh with the Blaster
strike whoa whoa uh she looks so good
and then we also have the whisper
investor which is her Double Daggers
um I'm gonna go with the night star it's
trusty and traditional foreign
[Music]
places you
do deeper into the game so the demo is
not starting you out like at the
beginning of the game where you'll see
when the actual retail is there
um but it definitely gives you a Feeling
of uh
for yourself
actually so if you're at the game you'll
collect different sidearms um and you'll
also collect different trinkets he'll
save you on your quest but there's also
level up aspects to it in the game if
you collect enough bones you'll bone up
uh it's the cool little catchphrase so
uh you can get strong in different ways
get better depends
a lot of fun
again Link at link energy here
I'm like uh it's really cool like I I
love the Gameboy Color and we are using
a lot of like Game Boy Color logic to it
we're staying faithful to like the color
palette there is some cheese just like
how we did uh with a Shovel Knight this
little side cheating that quiet uh the
static-wise it's it's beautiful it's so
thin I think what's exciting about that
is like
the way you guys create the aesthetic
here it makes you think your old games
actually looked in Ran this way and they
did they did it really they were they
you know they were slower there was a
lot of capitulation and flashing and you
guys obviously clean that up immensely
while maintaining the art style so in my
mind all my old games look like this
how you remember the Game Boy Color
rather than like how exactly it is
um like I always dreamed about playing
my game boy games on my TV which we did
have you know the Game Boy packs but it
isn't this it isn't this you take a Game
Boy Color game and you attach it to that
was it the N64 that you could attack
okay so there was the controller pack
thing right before you put it in there
and then there also was one for the
Super Nintendo right right
um but it wasn't it wasn't this I would
imagine it though you take those pixels
and you blow them up they're not pretty
not not as pretty as they should be but
yeah so tell us a little bit about uh
wall spice okay so for boss fights
you're actually going to have to find
out something to keep in mind it's our
compatible today
um is that for this game in comparison
to the Shovel Knight series is that for
this game uh we're Landing in the spooky
elements so as You Adventure through
September and other like levels I don't
think we've announced the name for yet
um going to discover very uh
I would say yeah like spooky very dark
themes to it so the enemies will be a
little bit more uh yeah
than the double Night series Lost by
surf challenging but they're going to be
fun I had mentioned earlier um a little
bit of uh bloodborne aspects to it so
Shovel Knight you had mentioned earlier
with uh inspired by Mega Man and
DuckTales but it also is inspired by a
Dark Souls so we're continuing that
tradition for me to so there'll be a lot
of dodging a lot of whipping around and
you know keeping your wits as sharp is
your night star to make sure that
everything goes smoothly I wouldn't have
it any other way
so excited for being at the house
uh release date not announced so what's
the game uh the devs give me the thumbs
up we'll start you know spreading to the
world when me and holler will come out
but until then it's unannounced but keep
an eye on our social media Pages we're
at Yacht Club games on literally
everything
um and I'll announce it when I can
absolutely thank you so much this is
Lord Sovereign back again this is Yacht
Club games this is Mina the Howard shout
out to iron Lords podcastgaming.net